Il s'agit de poser les bonnes questions.
Mais il peut révéler de nombreuses opportunités
de test de nos hypothèses biologiques.
Si nos prévisions correspondent à nos observations,
génial ! Nous avons raison, nous pouvoir faire d'autres prévisions
en changeant cet aspect-ci ou cet aspect-là du modèle.
Si, cependant, nos prévisions ne correspondent pas à nos observations,
certaines de nos hypothèses sont fausses
et notre compréhension des mécanismes clés
qui sous-tendent la biologie
est encore incomplète.
Heureusement, puisque c'est un modèle,
nous contrôlons toutes les hypothèses.
Nous pouvons les passer en revue, une à une,
pour identifier laquelle ou lesquelles sont à l'origine de la divergence.
Nous pouvons remplir cette lacune de savoir nouvellement identifiée
en utilisant des approches expérimentales et théoriques.
Bien sûr, tout écosystème est extrêmement complexe
et essayer de décrire tous les parties en mouvement est très difficile
mais aussi très informatif.
Il y a aussi le problème des durées
car certains processus se réalisent sur une échelle en secondes, en minutes,
en jours, en mois ou en années.
Il n'est pas toujours possible de les séparer expérimentalement.
Certaines choses se produisent si vite ou si lentement
que nous ne sommes jamais physiquement capables de les mesurer.
Mais en tant que mathématiciens,
nous avons le pouvoir de nous concentrer
sur n'importe quel système et n'importe quelle durée
et de simuler les effets d'interventions
qui ont lieu sur n'importe quelle durée.
Bien sûr, ce n'est pas le travail d'un seul modélisateur.
Cela doit arriver en étroite collaboration avec des biologistes.
Cela requiert une capacité de traduction
des deux côtés.
Mais démarrer avec une formulation théorique d'un problème
peut révéler de nombreuses opportunités de test des hypothèses,
de simulations de scénarios et d'interventions thérapeutiques
de façon entièrement sûre.
Cela peut identifier des lacunes de savoir et des incohérences logiques
et nous guider vers ce que nous devrions continuer à explorer
et ce qui pourrait être une impasse.
En d'autres mots :
la modélisation mathématique peut nous aider à répondre à des questions
qui affectent directement la santé des gens --
la santé de chaque personne --
car la modélisation mathématique sera la clé
d'une médecine personnalisée.
Tout cela repose sur le fait de poser la bonne question
et de la traduire en la bonne équation ...
et inversement.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)